sometimes you have to fail in order to  be your best version of self at some  point in the future that's a necessary  component to the crucible you know you  got to go through some of that in order  to know where you're going to succeed  and really shine i was so terrified to  hear  that message because it was very  counter-intuitive for me it was at a  time in my life where i was like is this  is this it for me is this every day is  going to be like this for me until i die  or until i retire you know safe little  401k is that is that what it is  and  the idea that that was what it would be  was very sad to me i didn't want that so  hearing that message that hey you're 40  years old and you can totally do  something new and different and exciting  you're still allowed to have dreams at  this point was terrifying but also  electrifying